what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
players stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion would
bond I see my veins forget John Terry
I'm the real mr. steal yo girl what up
yo Linda is hurricane season we do that
one more time
I already quit get that more lenders I
can tourism which kidnap turn here
board up your windows it's harry kane
season taping women to go here you go
here David you Paris I hear what not
Amanda cosa speaks here remember we have
six seconds to impact us on six seconds
got it no you speak too fast we just
shoot some paintballs already last year
the guys went paintballing after a loss
in the a mega afterwards we won the
Premier League so I think why not we do
it again this year it's funny I like to
get into it I like pretend them all
American whenever I'm doing gun things
Kyle Walker Texas Ranger it's not bad
right
pretty good now the company spot at 11
o'clock Bravo Company you ready I can't
do it oh come on it's all in fun no I
mean I just pulled my calf oh ah it
hurts it's just pain means in no I
pulled my other calf guys here here
quickly count the counter hmm
wait we are not using this red paint
scouts liver ah
now I actually got the pimple shot of
the year for that Toma okay guys be
careful but there is one right there is
always a nothing new by these bastards
never walk alone what are they doing
they seem to be playing a game but they
have this upside down frowns and say I'm
making sounds like hahaha
it's called smiling and having fun
overrated don't get any ideas
oh now pep appears to be yelling at
someone it's Jurgen drop what they are
not the real rivals I am peps only true
competition he and this German hack had
fling back in Bundesliga now everyone
wants to act like they are great
adversaries
it is a disrespect to all of Manchester
and the history of the Derby but even
more important than that it is
disrespect to me God why do you have to
ruin everything
or unbeaten season of Champions League
ops and not this we're just having a
little fun
no we are the fun team clearly you have
not seen all or nothing and clearly you
haven't seen James Milnes Twitter yes
but everybody knows I'm the most worki
likeable manager and football probably
I'm just the normal guy exactly wait
that was very like dammit well nobody's
more likable than David Silva except for
masala now you truly are my greatest
rival you clever clever and you are mine
you brilliant fault barcelonian
oh my god get a room you two you're I'm
your rival I'm everyone to rival I'm the
most decorated alibi your rival Josie
not you
[Music]